[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages time then to see
what's making the headlines with the
journalist and author Christina
Patterson and the editor of the Jewish
Chronicle Jake Wallace Simons great to
see both of you so as ever the front
pages first of all
let's start with the Observer which
reports that the Royal College of
Nursing is to ballot its members of
whether to join a so-called Mega strike
across the profession according to the
Sunday Mirror some of the NHS workers
campaigning for better pay have been
invited to the coronation
the mail on Sunday cites its own
reporting as the reason police were
aware of plans for protests by animal
rights groups before today's Grand
National National Disgrace is how the
Sunday people describes today's events
and the Racing Post remarks on the
disruption as well but chiefly it
celebrates today's win by coric Rambler
and jockey Derek Fox declaring he is
Unstoppable
meanwhile the Sunday Telegraph has news
of the Prime Minister scrapping the
building of any more smart motorways
amid concerns over safety and cost
the times reports there's to be a fresh
investigation into Ian Patterson they
form a cancer surgeon jailed for 20
years for conducting medically
unnecessary procedures on his patients
the Sunday Express says there are fears
that the monarchy could effectively
abolish itself as a result of spending
less time directly interacting with its
subjects and the star tells us that the
intelligence services are actively
recruiting people who are good at DIY
or one person maybe we'll get to that
I'm not sure anyway a reminder by
scanning the QR code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's papers
uh while you watch our guests so let's
head straight to them Christina
Patterson and Jake Wallace Simons are
here and we know that the health
secretary Christina has written in the
sun on Sunday talking about deep concern
now about strike action and here is the
Observer with the word Mega strike um
sending fear into all those in
government No Doubt
yes fear into all those in government
but also fear into a British people
actually I I mean in Western terms this
feels like a rather dangerous country to
be in at the moment because they nurses
are talking about not Staffing a e which
would be absolutely terrifying and the
doctor's uni and the BMA are now talking
about joining forces with nurses and
possibly even coordinating their strikes
which would clearly be an absolute
disaster I mean we've we've already
heard that excess deaths during strikes
have increased enormously I read one
report that said that were three times
as many excess deaths as usual during
the last strike I'm not sure if that's
accurate but if that's the case that
that then these assertions that they
want to strike but keep people safe are
unfortunately not true because people
have died the result of these strikes
it's it's just not accurate to say that
you can go on strike and keep people
safe you can't now that doesn't mean of
course people do have the right to
strike and I do think that the nurses in
particular had had a reason to strike
but also they were offered a pay deal
which the the RCN leaders having in my
view unreasonably asked for 19 were
happy to accept so and it looks as
though the margin was pretty slight for
so I I think it's a real shame that the
nurses didn't accept the offerer on the
table and I think it's a huge shame that
the BMA are demanding 35 have apparently
been taken over by a group of militant
leaders who are proud to call themselves
militant and the net result is misery
for people and and death so I of course
I support anyone's right to strike but I
think I think they need to sit down and
they need to do some proper negotiating
and I think the nurses should probably
think again
yes and of course the uh the junior
doctors say it's corrective rather than
a pay rise but using uh not a typical
form of inflate of inflation measure of
course as well as any Telegraph picks up
on that idea of the trade unions um
calling uh on on people to stick
together and strike together uh
suggesting that the Royal College of
nursing's 48-hour strike will take place
from April the 30th to the 2nd of May
the BMA which retains a mandate for
further strikes is seeking to to
coordinate its actions with other unions
and then the bmas deputy chair
um recently telling striking teachers
that unions should stick together and
strike together so not just Health
Services in a combined strike
um you know that that will definitely be
concerning uh won't it
yes I mean I like like Christina says
these strikes have really become immoral
particularly in the case of Nursing and
and especially the doctors you know
Junior doctors over there the period of
their career are very well remunerated
with a huge pension at the end of it
um it is not justified for them to put
the well-being uh and the lives of
hundreds of thousands of ordinary people
at risk for the sake of wanting this
absurd demand of a 35 increase which is
not as you pointed out
um in line with inflation it that
depends on the the RPI measure which has
been discredited
um it you know I it it's beyond me how
the doctors in particular and also the
nurses can look at themselves in the
mirror I think they're they're
withdrawing their care from people in
intensive care from cancer patients from
people in in a e and extending the
waiting list to 630
000 missed appointments as well
um and how they can look at themselves
in the mirror and tell themselves they
are fulfilling the Hippocratic Oath
there's absolutely appalling behavior
um the government made it a decent offer
to the nurses uh of a five percent
payoffer plus a bonus which was almost
accepted by the majority of the RCN
membership was accepted by Unison but
because of this minority holding out
they've been forced into even more
radical strikes uh which are going to be
combined with the junior doctors and now
we're here with the teachers as well so
it's a many frontal Onslaught on the
government at a time when the country is
suffering from high inflation which is
uh beginning to spiral
um but that's exactly why they're
striking isn't it because because of the
cost of living and that their pay
packets are not inflationary and the
lost money during the years of austerity
so whether you think they're well
remunerated or not and that their
pensions are better than the private
sector at the end the difficulty is
right now and that and that's the
problem isn't it and and the public
still have support for them too to be
fair
oh public support is waning and will
continue to wane and I think will
dwindle quite dramatically particularly
when the junior doctors become more and
more militant over time people can see
that these are unreasonable Demands a 35
increase is not a reasonable demand it
is not linked to inflation It is Well
above the rate of inflation that
everybody else has been suffering you
know everybody else in the country would
like a massive pay rise because we're
all suffering inflation but we're not
going on strike to get it these Junior
doctors are putting lives at risks and
risk and patients well-being at risk and
Ordinary People in the country are
suffering and public support will
reflect that and the opinion piece
written by Steve Barkley Mr Barclay
Health secretary and the sun on Sunday
patient safety is my first priority
industrial action means the safety of
patients is put at risk canceled
operations missed opportunities and
treatments postponed none of this is
good for the NHS or patients so the
words of the health secretary but
Christina we move on to the Sunday
people a national or Grand National
Disgrace a horse fell at the first and
died during this race 118 people
arrested the race
delayed as we know where do you stand on
this
well I I don't look I'm not a fan of
horse racing uh my late brother hugely
was and was always putting money on the
horses and occasionally won a few Bob
but
um I'm not I'm not deeply anti either
and I also don't go around disrupting
things I don't like or don't approve of
because I think it's undemocratic and
unfair on the people who do enjoy them
and I don't think that there is Major
evidence that horse racing is a kind of
hugely harmful sport it's not like fox
hunting or you know it's not a blood
sport
um horses are bred to race
so I I think it's I don't know I just uh
these I don't know what thrill people
get from gluing themselves to fences and
doing this kind of thing of course if
it's something like the right to vote
you know we all approved of the
suffragists
um who fought hard to gain women the
right to vote but I think people seem to
think that they have the right to
disrupt any activity now just because it
doesn't particularly correspond with
what they like or approve of and I think
I think people are extremely intolerant
of of things that are legal and regarded
by sort of democratic
um
opinion as okay and acceptable and I
just think I just wish that people could
you know they can write opinion pieces
they can express their views on social
media but do they actually have to wreck
a day out for all these people well I I
do think yeah but but changes have
already happened at Aintree haven't they
you know horses lower fences rather
lowered and softened and the horse that
died today Hill 16 who died at the first
of those fences from a broken neck it is
thought was the third to die at the
Grand National Festival now do they need
to have so many riders in that race is
that part of the problem is it an
overcrowded field do more changes need
to happen to to make this safer for both
horses and jockeys Jake
well I think that I mean as you point
out there have been some Innovations
that's been brought in this year and
this is something that the race
organizers are very aware of
um and every time a horse dies people's
consciousnesses are raised if you like
and people become more aware of the
dangers that horses are facing and I'm
sure next year there'll be even more
Innovations as well so gradually I think
the standards of Animal Welfare are
being raised and raised with each
passing year uh but I think that these
this action by um animal Rising they're
called they used to be called animal
Rebellion
um it doesn't do anybody any favors
they've delayed the race by 12 minutes
um it didn't really achieve anything
apart from some some headlines uh and
sensible people are already taking
measures to improve horse horse welfare
so hopefully that you know that will
continue over time in a sensible way and
in the meantime the 70 000 Spectators
and 600 million onlookers on television
sets around the world won't lose the the
wonderful spectacle of the race and just
very quickly if you don't mind for what
is in
Sudan the question whether this is you
know descending into Civil War whether
this is is a jostle for power
um your thoughts on that Christina
well briefly
a a militant a military group have
undertaken not exactly a military coup
but they claim to have um got control of
the presidential Palace and a couple of
airports so it's a reminder of how
unstable countries really can tip very
easily into a huge instability and you
know we hope not Civil War but Sudan has
seen so much violence and instability
over the years so it must be a very
frightening time to be there at the
moment and I just hope that it gets
resolved peacefully